y aquí en france 24 seguimos
entrevistando a líderes políticos y
sociales respecto a lo que ocurre
actualmente en colombia para ellos algo
en ese momento ha sido ramírez senador
del centro democrático o partido de
gobierno o senador
gracias por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 ante esta
situación que se ha generado en la
ciudad de cali en las últimas horas el
presidente dio la orden de levantar los
bloqueos podemos esperar otra noche de
enfrentamientos en cali
muy buenas noches gracias por la
invitación hoy estamos viendo como esta
estrategia criminal financiada con
recursos bastante dudosos
financia a los indígenas para sabotear
saquear y seguir situando a la ciudad de
cali la tercera ciudad de colombia hoy
la tienen bloqueada sitiada
desabastecimiento de medicinas de
oxígeno de gasolina de alimentos y eso
es lo que quiere generar este sector
político unido con la minga el caos y el
desgobierno la alcaldía y la gobernación
de ese departamento han pedido auxilio
al gobierno nacional para que tome el
control el presidente de la república ha
ordenado militarizar cal y la ciudadanía
también lo exigen los indígenas han
asaltado casas han decomisado han
exculpado a varios ciudadanos y le han
han agredido físicamente a muchos
habitantes de cali por eso es necesario
recuperar el orden lo más rápido posible
el senador le pregunto a qué grupo se
refiere que están detrás de esta minga
indígena también y qué pruebas tienen al
respecto
la minga indígena ha venido
supuestamente por una invitación de la
iglesia pero vemos como un candidato que
perdió las elecciones a la presidencia
sigue respaldando a esta minga sigue
auspiciando el caos y sigue auspiciando
la protesta no pacífica con los bloqueos
eso lo hemos visto en diferentes
intervenciones a través de las redes
sociales y hoy vemos que la ciudadanía
caleña implora la intervención rápida y
urgente de la fuerza pública en la
ciudad ahora porque el presidente de
colombia en duque no ha querido viajar a
la ciudad de cali para reunirse con
estos líderes del paro en esa ciudad
como lo están exigiendo desde hace días
y porque se han tardado tanto para
restaurar el orden público como usted lo
dice
el presidente la república lleva cuatro
días invitando a los líderes del paro en
todo el país a que se sienten a dialogar
con el gobierno nacional en cabeza del
presidente y de todos sus ministros el
líder es los del comité del paro no ha
querido asistir incluso han dicho que
todavía hasta el lunes fue hasta quién
sabe qué día no han querido decir que
días se van a sentar ahora creo que
dicen que mañana según el ministro de
trabajo
estamos esperando primero que se
controle el orden público yo también
pienso que el presidente la república en
las próximas horas o días empezará a
recorrer el país garantizando el orden
público yo pienso que ese es el momento
para darle la tranquilidad al país y que
las personas que han protestado
pacíficamente pacíficamente se sienten
con el gobierno nacional a dialogar y
empezar a generar soluciones reales
reales para ponerle finales
ahora hablando de soluciones le pregunto
senador le recordamos a la gente senador
ciro ramírez del centro democrático
partido gobierno que soluciones pueden
aportar ustedes como un partido de
gobierno a esta crisis política y social
que vive colombia
hemos nosotros ha hablado de generar
espacios de diálogo incluso lo hemos
venido haciendo nosotros con sectores
políticos económicos y sociales
diferentes al nuestro no solo a nivel
nacional sino a nivel local es
importante generar estos espacios ayudar
a que cesen los bloqueos para parar el
desabastecimiento de vacunas oxígeno
alimentos gasolina y obviamente no caer
en esta disputa política yo pienso que
es un momento de altura en su momento de
separar nuestras diferencias políticas y
llamar a la calma llamar a la no
violencia no a los bloqueos y salir
rápidamente con mensajes que den
solución a cuáles mensajes que quiere la
ciudadanía